well delighted to have you here thank
you for making the trip out here to be
here yeah it's gonna be cool so so many
things to talk about but why don't we
just why don't we just start at the
beginning and I'm gonna ask you
questions I already know the answer to
but the people that listening don't are
how did you get started in this whole
world of animal advocacy and activism to
begin with like the beginning the
beginning it's like you know set the
stage set the stage well like most human
beings my first encounter with animals
was as a child and I grew up in the
swamps of Florida where there were ducks
in my backyard and if anyone is to blame
or to thank for my life of animal
activism it is a family of ducks yeah
and they would hatch in my mother's
prized
flower bed which we were not allowed to
touch of course but the mother ducks
were and they would come in and you know
push around all the flowers and make a
nest and this these eggs would hatch and
it was right on the other side of his
screened-in porch mm-hmm so my brother
sister and I used to lay in our bellies
and watched the lives of these ducks
unfold hatch go out for their first swim
and all the dramas and there are dramas
when it comes to ducks that unfold so I
grew up with no question in my mind that
animals that we were not talking we were
just talking about degrees of difference
between us and ducks and dogs and cats
and cows and pigs and they were worthy
of good lives and worthy of protection
and when I grew you know I always had
this great appreciation for nature but
when I grew up and around 15 discovered
that animals are horribly abused in our
food system totally disregarded as
sentient beings rather than be really
sad about that I became just a fire was
ignited in me
know something about it what was your
upbringing like with your parents that
did they instill in you a sense of you
know responsibility or you know how did
that how did that engine come about was
that something that you saw in you know
the way that your parents conducted
themselves yes so two examples related
to the Ducks of course my father you
know this was in the 80s and he would
dressed in his suit and tie the first
time the Ducks would go out into the
canal he'll be very concerned about this
because it is not a happy place for
ducks necessary ducklings there's otters
and Gators and he used to follow them in
an aluminum canoe with a net and if one
of them kind of got too far behind he
would scoop up the Ducks careful not to
touch them get his scent on them and
make sure that they got reunited with
the pack and the flock of you know so
yeah and on the other hand my and my mom
also sometimes the Ducks would lay the
eggs out of season and in the winter it
sometimes gets cold in Florida and she
they would very late my mom and the
mother ducks had this Spang going on and
she would lay the eggs underneath the
dryer vent and my mom if the mother duck
went out to get food or do her thing and
have a break my mom would turn on the
dryer vent and make sure it was like her
personal responsibilities like you know
an extended family yeah they really were
an extended thing I knew about the Ducks
I didn't realize it was so intense it
was well there was this thing where you
you moot you move away from Florida and
then you move back right a couple years
later or something like that right and
then suddenly the Ducks were no more
right I I moved to Spain and then moved
back when I was 17 and I remember the
moai with looking around and I didn't
quite know what I was looking for and I
realized the Ducks weren't there anymore
and in that time the chemicals that are
put on lawns to keep them Green and weed
free had run into this canal and turned
it into a pea soup it was just algae and
smelting yeah and the Ducks had left
and in some ways I was very sad but I
was also very glad that they could leave
because later though I would discover
not only animals have that choice right
and your first kind of stab at activism
had to do with manatees right yeah the
beloved manatee I love if I could be any
animal I would be a manatee why is that
you just get to chill in the Florida
waterways and eat vegan food yeah the
best manatees are they you know I I love
the Florida waterways I love the
wildlife and the nature and manatees are
this unlikely animal to be in these
waterways these giant sea cows that just
hang out so I worked for save the
manatee club as my first job yeah and
that's where I discovered policy makes a
difference government policy makes a
difference because the battle for the
manatee was also the battle for prime
real estate in Florida which was
waterway real estate and the law was
that endangered there they were
classified as an endangered species and
therefore if they were on a property you
cannot build a marina there mm-hmm and
that was valuable property yeah well
that seems to sort of presage or set the
stage for your particular perspective on
advocacy being one of working in
cooperation and partnership with these
institutions to shift them from within
which is considered by some to be a
radical departure from the traditional
methodology of trying to you know win
the hearts and minds of the individuals
and consider these institutions as you
know emblematic of the enemy yeah right
yeah I think I very quickly realized
that if you want to change things you
have to convince the enemy to join you
and get on your path with you even if
you start a little further back than
you'd like it's a it's a more
sustainable
long-term change that ends the battle it
really you know you don't I think when
your early on in activism the battle
feels great like you're so angry and you
want to be angry and you want to blame
someone but you get worn out that way
mm-hmm and at some point you take a step
back and it doesn't feel good anymore
and you realize you're not making as
much progress you're just being angry
and just spinning your wheels get
probably getting angrier and angrier you
you're facing more and more resistance
because there's a there's a certain
futility to it as well
I think definitely and and I still get
really angry it's not I think that the
mistake is that I'm not endorsing what's
happening and engaging doesn't mean
endorsing and that's an important
distinction right I think people get
confused about that they do and and I
get I mean I get plenty of you know the
hate that really and I get where it's
coming from it's a fear that we're
degrading or losing our position but
that's not what it is engaging is at
worst you're gonna understand better how
to fix the problem and at best you find
a common ground that you can build from
right well it seems it seems elemental
to me that understanding is foundational
to creating change if you don't
understand the playing field and the
players and you don't find a way to you
know at least empathize with them in
some way then you're starting from you
know behind the starting line in terms
of your ability to really you know right
I need to change you see I mean the
industry we're trying to change factory
farming it's super secretive and the
people but the people who do it the
industry the farmers they know
everything we want to know but can't
know unless we get to know them about
changing it and that's what as I started
to work with these farmers all the
questions I had wanted to know we're
being answered just by befriending these
people and trying to understand their
perspective and then giving me open
tours of their factory farms I could ask
the questions like how often are these
chickens dying is
normal you know how often do these
disease outbreaks happen what happens
when the disease outbreaks happen in
your farm who helps you do these go on
to people's plate like all these
questions you just can't know the answer
to unless you step inside the problem
you can't even get the opportunity to
ask them though unless you engender some
level of trust that is a good point and
that that's that probably for a decade
was the most frustrating thing for me is
we would have these questions and we
couldn't ask anybody nobody would even
pick up the phone answer an email and
that's when we started switching from
when I started switching really from
hardcore advocacy to more engagement and
more let me just write a nice email
instead of a nasty one I know nom
imagine that imagine yeah well let's
work our way up to that I mean first you
you you go to college and then you go to
London right to get a graduate degree
and like sustainable development yeah
and was there was part of that motivated
by just trying to learn as much as you
could about agriculture and farming or
was there a sense that this was gonna be
your path I feel like the path chose me
mm-hmm
probably a lot of people feel that way
no I felt pulled towards something and I
didn't know what but I was just
following the doors as they opened and
when I finished I did a zoology degree
at University of Florida and I really
cared about the waterways of Florida I
really thought that's what I was gonna
do that I was gonna do environmental
protection I thought I needed to be a
vet maybe I would do that nary wildlife
rescue you know be doing really fun
wildlife marine rescue work and my
mentor at the time took me aside and he
said Leah that's not what you want to do
that's our plumbers they fix animals
once they're already broken you're more
interested in getting to the root of the
problem the root of the suffering and
that was probably the most important
thing anyone's ever said to me in terms
of defining my path mmm-hmm he doesn't
probably even know that and it was dr.
Lewis Gillette and
that made me look at master's degrees at
the time there were not really
sustainable development that was just an
emerging concept really it was 1999 and
there were two degrees one was in London
it we were the first batch of students
and the other one was in Boston
University and I just looked at the cost
of those and I was like okay London and
I read to London there's probably a lot
of those programs now there are tons and
the program now has you know a thousand
kids in it and it's part of University
of London Kings College that I went to
but there were seven of us in the
program and we kind of got to define it
a little bit ourselves and it was
fantastic but the of all places England
right I chose the kind of random place a
random country I had been born and grown
up partially in Spain I wanted to get
back to Europe and when I got there I
discovered this whole farm animal
movement happening that I had no idea
that aligned exactly with my values and
I just I had no idea that was a possible
career option mm-hmm so more than
getting my master's degree there I was
exposed to compassionate world farming
the Royal Society for the Protection of
animals a bunch of really hardcore
groups like Viva or other animal rights
farm animal rights organisations that
not only were they were professional
there were professional movement of like
with CEOs and communication specialists
and lobbyists fighting for farmed
animals and they had already won lots of
things like they had banned the worst
practices which we still haven't in this
country right like battery cages and
these crates that mother pigs are kept
in and veal crates bamned mm-hmm and
they had succeeded and I just got I
would fell in love and then you just you
ended up working with them for a while
right and then coming to the United
States and kind of opening up the
satellite office from from one
Gainesville to another yes yes I have a
thing for games house yeah I worked for
ten years in Europe in
Londyn I work for compassionate wool
farming and then I worked at world
Society for the Protection of animals
where I oversee oversaw all of the
global campaigns and programs and during
that period of my life I went to 30
countries before I was 30 and saw every
form of suffering that human beings
inflict on animals whether it be
dolphins and dolphinariums bear bile
farming stray dogs horses being used for
work working horses used in Colombia and
then farm animals and I really thought
after the birth some of that my son was
born in in London and when he was born
things really switched for me because I
really thought about the world I wanted
to hand him and I thought my time is
also very precious now because he's
precious and you know when your kids are
born you have this moment where you're
like time is now really precious like in
18 years 18 years you've got 18 years
you seem to have a very finally acutely
calibrated clock though like you're
you're you're you know like you're you
don't have a lot of patience and you're
very you know sensitive to how time is
passing and and time is short yeah it is
much to the annoyance of many people
around me I just did this like three we
just did this 360 degree review
internally for Mercy for Animals and it
was all very positive for my team but
all of them were like can we please slow
down please can we go slower what's an
interesting dynamic because my sense of
what it must be like to try to shift
these gigantic institutions from within
requires you know a deft hand and you
know a sort of mature diplomatic
disposition and with that patience right
these these things don't turn around on
a dime so yeah how do you reconcile like
the patience that that demands with your
impatience to see the change that you
know you envision in your mind in the
world that's a very astute observation
then I have never
I guess I think it's worthy of my
patience if it's going to move a large
number of individuals from and reduce
their suffering so I have patience for
if I'm working with a company and I know
they're in charge of half a million
animals and if I so working with Purdue
for example they produce they raise and
slaughter six hundred and eighty million
animals every year mm-hmm so having
patience with them is worth it because
even a tiny step is a monumental
reduction in suffering for those animals
and that makes it more worth it do you
have to go into those meetings thinking
okay I have to be patient I have to
clamp down on my impatience a little bit
yeah yeah I stay very goal-oriented and
come up with two or three things and I'm
like these are the things I really want
to move them on and staying focused like
that helps me stay patient I guess so
your husband gets a job offer from CDC
all right so this is gonna take you to
Georgia yes and and at that time were
you thinking well this is gonna you know
allow me to explore the the belly of the
beast in terms of the chicken industry
or Hut you know how did that it was
perfectly aligned right that he would
get this job offer and it would it would
sort of intersect perfectly with this
thing at you're super interesting yeah
like I said I feel like the path pulled
me and I had proposed to the
compassionate world forming CEO of this
satellite office and I said we're
probably gonna move it's gonna be
Georgia but here's why it should be
Georgia Georgia is the largest producing
state of chickens in the entire country
they produce 1.4 billion chickens every
single year it's where factory farming
was born essentially chicken factory
farming in particular and what's the
point of being another nonprofit that's
pointing fingers from the city not
really getting it let me be in the thick
of it and he didn't say yes right away
and we moved anyway but I started
working despite that she's doing it yeah
yeah I just started explore
and I got on the board of the gorge
animal rights and protection and just
just started getting into it and then
about a year after I had moved there he
called me and said I remember that
proposal I found the money here's two
days of pay and a laptop go oh wow so
you were do it you were kind of on your
own for a whole year before yeah yeah
well my two days yeah yeah well that's
not you yeah yeah you know a lot of a
lot of us believe that it's just you
know you just hand a laptop in a work
right it does half the time so it's
worth trying and here's where things get
really interesting you know I knew that
Georgia was a was a large poultry
producer I didn't realize the extent you
know to which it's responsible for all
the chickens that Americans eat so just
to kind of canvas the landscape in the
United States nine billion chickens a
year are slaughtered for human food so
one point six of those billion come come
out of Georgia right it's like a huge
percentage of their sort of state GDP
right yeah it's like the number one
industry in Georgia and what's really
interesting and you go into this in
detail in the book is the history of how
industrialized chicken farming came to
be and really the roots of animal agnus
of conventional factory farming can be
traced back to their origins in rural
Georgia yeah there was this gentleman
named Jesse Joule and he owned a feed
mill and he wanted to figure out how to
sell more of this feed so this is like
the grain that we feed animals so his
idea and this was during the Depression
was that he would get farmers to rent
chickens from him by his feed and then
he picked them up at the end and send
them off to slaughter and this would
help him grow his feed business and it
worked and this was in Gainesville
Georgia and this was this is essentially
how the system works today so he got
enough money that he also bought the
processing plant the slaughterhouse
so he ended up owning the whole system
which is a vertically integrated system
that we see today and why the farmers
that I worked with later
you know are essentially indentured
servants they can't get out of this
system they are not they don't know and
then they don't know in those chickens
the chickens are dropped off their
chicken babysitters and then they grow
them and then someone else picks them up
and send them off to slaughter and that
was Jesse Jewell then it's Perdue and
Tyson today mm-hmm so I think a lot of
people I mean I've talked about this on
the podcast before and we've gone into
this but but not to the detail with
which you kind of unpack it in your book
like I think it's worth really trying to
understand the predicament that these
farmers find themselves in from a
financial perspective like you have a
well-meaning individual who wants to
hold on to their land they take these
loans out so that they can build these
you know basically warehouses for these
you know to breed these chickens and
they become indentured servitude because
although they're promised like this
pathway forward in terms of being able
to pay down this loan they keep getting
hit with requirements to improve their
facilities etc and are required to
continually take take out loans and they
can barely make ends meet and it's
really it creates a you know a
legitimate socio-economic problem where
these people are trapped in a situation
that quickly becomes something I never
would have predicted it would become
yeah I collectively chicken factory
farmers in our country Oh 5.2 billion
dollars Wow that's how much debt they
have and as you said so just the example
that I learned like the really just
rocked my world was one farmer craig
watts he lives in Fairmont North
Carolina and when he was about 22 years
old he was dreaming for a way to stay on
the land that had been passed down five
generations in his family and many of
the farmers are like that they just want
to stay there for either away life or
because this was their family's house
land farm for a hundred years and in
this case tobacco industry bottom doubt
North Carolina chicken industry rolls up
right behind it and offers Craig this
contract and it seems like a dream come
true he can stay on the land he can pay
his bills he can raise his family and he
takes a quarter of a million
all our loan out which 22 in the poorest
county of north carolina seems to me
crazy but he can on the system allows
that to happen and he raises these loans
are guaranteed by Purdue right so
somebody they're guaranteed by taxpayers
they're part of our agricultural system
and if they fail they are backed by the
US government Wow yeah this is a whole
nother so a young individual with no
credit has no problem getting one of
these loans right and you know no
degrees like no problem and that's added
up to 5.2 billion dollars of debt in our
country and so you know he he took out
this loan he builds these warehouses and
at first it goes great and then the
birds start to get sick because it's a
factory farm and these are birds that
are stuffed wall-to-wall in a windowless
warehouse living on their own feces
ammonia Laden air stressful
circumstances and some of them die and
you don't get paid for dead birds and so
he starts to fall behind on the payments
he's supposed to be paying them off his
this loan off like a mortgage every
month the same amount every month is due
but if he doesn't raise X number of
chickens he doesn't he gets a smaller
paycheck right and he starts to fall
behind on that loan and he has take out
more money or he has to do something
else he has another job to make ends
meet and pretty soon he's realized he's
made a mistake
but too late and he's an indentured
servant and he can't do anything about
it
and that is the typical circumstance in
his case he it was going good initially
and so then he kind of doubled down
right like he had two warehouses and he
went to four so he took out more debt
that subsidized that and the problems
then kind of started to creep up then
right and the way it works is you take
out these loans Purdue is responsible
for getting you the chicks right and you
kind of cover everything else you raise
these birds and then they basically come
and pick them up right and you get pay
for whatever ones are usable I use it
you know the farmers get paid today five
cents per pound of bird of flesh and we
pay at the supermarket
if you eat chickens
a dollar that's the commodity price so
the farmer is getting five percent of
that dollar and there are many many many
of them are living on the edge of
poverty right are they yeah there was
like a crazy statistic something like
seventy-one percent of them are at or
below line yeah it's you know it's
serious and that was uh you know I was
like I'm a vegan animal rights activist
before I met Craig Watts this was the
person who symbolized everything I
fought against my whole career this is a
person who I hated I blamed I was angry
at I wished ill I did not want him to
succeed in life but he becomes the
flashpoint in your career and in this
movement right there's a there's a
decision to try to engage him from his
perspective from his point of view yeah
I mean being really honest I didn't when
I went to meet him that was not my
intention my intention was to go in
there and get footage because as you and
your listeners will be aware ag-gag is a
growing problem where it's illegal for
us to get footage inside of a lot of
farms so here was a guy offering me to
film freely in his farm and we hadn't
seen through at that time this was six
years ago there had not been footage
from inside a chicken factory farming
farm for a decade oh wow no one had been
able to get in it just was impossible so
this offer was like gold to me like I
had to get inside get footage and get it
out to the public but when I got there
something else happened completely you
know but there was a lot of email back
and forth and you know like trying to
feel each other out and he had to get to
a certain comfort level before he said
okay once you come on over yeah we were
texting we were emailing and you know I
remember it was like it was like a
Sunday and my family were eating in the
other room and I kind of finally worked
up the courage to say can I come kind of
bring a camera and he just said sure hmm
which had never happened before really
no I had been writing and trying to
contact
these companies saying can I get a tour
like very openly trying to legally and
openly see these places without doing
undercover work and they don't even
respond they wouldn't even respond so
one of the things that's interesting you
were talking to as recline about this
and he pointed it out and I I don't know
that I'd fully which was a great
conversation by the way I'd loved it
he pointed something out that I'm not
sure I really fully appreciated which is
the fact that due to these ag-gag laws
in the system being the way that it is
we've kind of normalized that Oh in this
industry like we're just not allowed to
know what's going on with our food and
we we we've sort of accepted that on
some level which is very odd because
that would be anathema in any other
industry and yet here we are prevented
from the free right to really get a
transparent perspective on how our food
is made yeah and that you have the only
source of information are these you know
underground undercover pursuits where
people sneak in in the middle of the
night and capture this footage it is
unfathomable to me that this is our
current food and farming system that all
of the animal protein comes from systems
that are out of sight and out of mind
for our country and for the world that
how can that be the I this is what
really drives me is this insistence in
my head and my mind and my soul that if
people really knew if they really saw I
just don't think anybody would would
want that to be where their protein came
from and it's a whole system that's
hoodwinking everyone in the process even
some of the executives even they are
removed from it who are running these
companies I find I mean they this is the
result of you know gigantic political
and lobbying forces like moving the
tectonic plates at the highest level
yeah it's not the farmers decision right
and the lobbyists are you know the our
politicians unfortunately are being
quite often paid by these lobbyists
these it makes it very difficult we
don't have one piece of federal
legislation protecting farmed animals on
farm in this country that's crazy
it's unbelievable it is
but it's necessary to continue this this
blindness that we that is instilled on
us what is the lobbying budget of the
Purdue's and the Tyson's I don't know
that off the top of my head because
sometimes we think about that we think
about like what is the advertising
budget we need or or what is the
lobbying budget we would need to
out-compete and it's really we can't
entertain that question no so when
you're when you're communicating with
with Craig before he invites you over
was there was there a sense like I mean
you kind of had to approach this more
from a journalist perspective than an
activist perspective right so was there
a sense like oh this guy you know is
having some second thoughts about how he
does what he does
and there's a little opening here did
you think like oh he's gonna he could be
a whistleblower or you're just thinking
I got to get in here before he changes
his mind and get this footage I think I
was genuinely curious like who is this
person why would he trust me and I
wanted to get to know him I wanted you
know also to get this footage because I
thought it was the last opportunity a
rare opportunity to find it to find to
get this footage out into the world that
can't usually see how the chickens are
being produced and you know I don't I
don't know why Craig and I met or how
that we were introduced by a journalist
but I did go into it I think because of
that with a bit of a journalist's mm-hmm
you know perspective well the way it
happened was was Craig slipped a bunch
of information to a journalist about the
feed right which is kind of proprietary
information right and then you met with
the journalist and you're like where did
this come from so there was evidence
like hey this guy you know yeah he wants
people to know what's really going on
here yeah and it really surprised me
yeah he I went to the coffee shop in my
town and this this journalist from
Reuters Brian crow he asked me to meet
cuz he heard I knew about this stuff and
he's like what is all this and I I was
like what do you have here he had a
bunch of he had like 10 years of the
antibiotics that
put into chicken feed like the exact
records from the farm and I thought he
was gonna say I snuck it out
I had an undercover and he said no this
farmer gave it to me mmm think who what
would he meet with me and I definitely
thought the answer be no I'm not doing
that I'll break my relationship and he
was like let me text him and he text him
right then and there and that's how we
got connected the surprising thing for
me from that story was that that's
confidential
like the feed that they're giving the
chicken is something that they don't
want anyone to know yeah they act like
it's their secret recipe that they don't
want their competitors to know about
that's how they excuse that but it's
really a veil to prevent the public from
right knowing what's going on 80% of our
antibiotics are given to farmed animals
and this isn't a time when they're
becoming ineffective like we are quickly
and rapidly approaching a time a
post-antibiotic period again like before
penicillin and that's frightening and
we're wasting it on farmed animals I
mean we're right now we're in the midst
of this coronavirus you know outbreak
and so it's very much on my mind the
impact of all of these you know
antibiotic fed animals and the
downstream impact of that and creating
you know a situation in which were we're
producing a scenario where an outbreak
like that is almost inevitable like some
kind of you know anti biotic resistant
strain of something will emanate out of
all of this that's going to create like
havoc yeah and I mean the corona virus
is it's very frightening and it came
from an animal market and that's I think
it's yeah and it's been spread you know
the recommendation if you look on the
CDC's page is don't eat any of it don't
eat animals for markets don't eat
animals right now from this region
we're not precisely sure and like why
can't that be the general advice from
the CDC
don't eat animals okay yeah and a lot of
the disease outbreaks we've seen avian
flu or you know the they have come from
the trading the eating the
reduction of animals in an totally
unhealthy an unsustainable way so you
get slipped this information you got
this opening from Craig and you go visit
him so tell me what happens
well we drove there with my friend Regan
ha and she's a filmmaker and the whole
way there he is writing really strange
text messages to us it turns out he's a
very jokey kind of guy but we didn't
know him at this stage so we just
thought maybe he is like screwing with
unhinged or he's on him and here we are
two women like headed in to God knows
where
and we're meeting with this man who by
all you know any other scenario would be
my an enemy that's the normal the media
pitches us that way is sworn enemies I
sent I remember I sent my husband the
address and said I'm going here if I
don't come back look for me buried in
the chicken litter you might actually be
rotting away that's where he might be
and it was like not a joke I really
thought this is a little scary and you
know he showed up and he led us into his
living room and we sat there for hours
and hours and hours and he was showing
me everything and I had this as he's
telling me his story you know I was
waiting for the right moment to say can
we go to your houses but it just didn't
come for hours because I was so
enthralled and engaged by his story as a
human being how he was showing me
footage of the the disease inside of his
houses how he had tried to get rid of it
how there was no help and no answer and
all the while he's falling behind on his
payments how he had been awarded as a
top grower he showed me it's like hats
for being at the top of the tournament
system they have or they get growers to
compete against each other he showed me
the pictures of his children of his
parents his grandparents he talked about
the the deed of the land from the Queen
of England that had been given to his
aunt and this is the land you know he
showed me the gravestone we walked to on
the property to his gravestones of his
family and I just you know sitting there
I remember looking out out the window
and thinking if I had been born Craig
Watts
but I've done anything different I don't
know what you know it's just seems you
have these moments when you meet people
who are very different than you where
you realize it's really chance that you
were born where you were born and how
unfortunate that he was born into a
situation where there were very few
options I genuinely believe he chose the
best one for himself and his family and
it was a mistake and he can't get out of
it now yeah Wow
I mean to have that kind of awareness I
think it's super important you know the
cornerstone of the vegan movement animal
rights movement is compassion right and
if we can't figure out a way to identify
you know with the person that we're
communicating with if we can't develop
compassion for that person how do you
it's how do you expect to create
sustainable change yeah and I think it's
really powerful you know to understand
that these farmers are people and
they're living in you know they have
these people are not the enemy they're
just trying to live their lives and make
good choices and they're dealing with
the deck that they've been given right
and it's the same with slaughterhouse
workers yeah very similar where a lot of
these are are immigrants they're migrant
workforces immigrant workforces that are
coming from Central America with very
few choices and they're the jobs nobody
else wants because they're dangerous
especially Latinas women are abused in
these processing plants these
slaughterhouses so it's it's this system
is not just about the suffering of the
animals it's also about the suffering of
the people that are producing our meat
and it's immense
right but what was different about Craig
I'm eeen he's in a community where
there's lots of people doing with what
he's doing who are in the same situation
that he's in essentially so what was it
that tipped him over and compelled him
to
you know make this decision to want to
share this his plight and the kind of
systemic things that he was dealing with
he was towards the end of his debt he
was getting close to it and I think he
said so he says said to me that the
thing that really made him switch was he
was watching a commercial on TV and it
was a Purdue commercial and it was Jim
Purdue saying in a pickup truck like all
our chickens are super happy and all our
farmers are super happy and yeah eat
chicken and he's he like something blew
up in him right and he's like I just
can't I can't I have kids like I cannot
look them in the eye and be a part of
this and he and I the funny thing is I
watched the same commercial and it
became the subject of our video because
it was I was like you cannot call this
humanely raised I know it's not you're
not you're not being transparent there's
no information this this I had gone
probably at the same time as him in a
parallel explosion in my head about
being mad that the consumers were being
lied to you yeah because in parallel
with all of this there is a sensibility
that consumers you know nobody wants to
think about the fact that these animals
are killed for their food let alone you
know harmed or you know treated poorly
and so to address that rather than kind
of you know rectify that in a real way
there's a lot of greenwashing going on
and a lot of labels getting thrown
around that you know aren't regulated
and are you know if if defined at all
are poorly defined and you talk about
that in the book right like going to the
store and saying tell me what this means
and like nobody being able to actually
you know give you a proper definition
because truly there isn't one it's just
marketing yeah and it's playing on the
good intentions and good will of the
public who like you said they don't want
to buy a torture nobody wants to buy or
eat a tortured animal nobody they want
to believe and will go to great lengths
to convince himself that the animal had
a good life so it's not very hard you
just have to put a green a green logo on
there that makes it look ma
and maybe say the words cage-free
chicken on there now mind you all meat
chickens are cage free so they're also
then you can see that on labels a lot
they're playing off the fact that people
want cage free eggs and most of the eggs
we're coming from caged hens and so they
look for these labels that you know are
really tricking people and the companies
there there's a lot of they're doing it
legally in a lot of cases so the case of
calling chicken cage free was brought to
a judge and the judge said well it's the
fact they're cage free but people are
buying it because they think they're a
pastor right right it's not it's not the
technical you know definition of it it's
the intention behind it which is in
Vince people that that these animals are
living happy lives yeah an unfortunate
our legal system is more on the side of
those companies then on the side of what
are the consumer consumers really seeing
here what are they really intending why
is it so hard to get effective labeling
laws and some appropriate regulation
here like what is the relationship
between the USDA and the industry and
you know where does political will sit
and how difficult is it to move that
needle it's a revolving door between
animal AG and the USDA you can you can
actually see and I forget the percentage
with a large percentage of the people
that are in USDA used to be an industry
the people in industry used to be in
USDA and they just go between the two
they know each other well they're all
buddies they hang out and the financing
of the campaign's of the politicians is
done by the AG industry to ensure later
when they're on the AG committee they're
resisting the progressive laws and
they're keeping the laws that maintain
the status quo in place it's just
heartening to hear that because you you
you you want to believe and I feel like
it would be you know expected as a
consumer and a citizen that the USDA is
the regulatory body and they're
providing the oversight to make sure
that everything is copasetic so that
when an
up on the plate it's safe and everything
is kind of vetted yeah you know tell me
the reality of this well I'll give you a
really very concerning example that's
happening right now which is the USDA
just approved allowed for
slaughterhouses to speed up their line
speeds so right that's a that's a this
is this is an this is recently right and
the Trump administration tracks setback
these rags yeah they've what used to
happen and this is still ridiculous it's
a hundred and twenty five birds per
minute can go on a line
now they've allowed you could go up to
175 birds per minute that is three birds
a second so 1 2 3 that's 9 birds that
just got slaughtered that's insane
not only that they have the USDA are
saying you know what we don't need to
police these places anymore we're not
gonna check for food safety and they're
allowing companies to police themself
grade their own papers that's super
insane it's going to have human health
repercussions
there will be outbreaks there will be
Campylobacter Salmonella e.coli that's
the USDA's job is to stop contaminated
meat from getting into our food system
mostly because we don't have laws to
protect farmed animals chickens
especially so their job is mostly one of
making sure they're following health and
safety regulations so also the people
that are working there that they're
being treated safely and help in a
healthy and work environment so we
actually and this is the same for pigs
also they just allowed the line speeds
to be increased for pigs and we are
suing Mercy for Animals is suing USDA
over this oh wow
when we think about animal rights and
and animal welfare the typical you know
what typically comes to mind are cattle
and pigs we kind of overlook chickens
right and fish for reasons I want to you
know explore with you but the truth of
the matter is like chicken is the number
one protein in country if not the world
right how do we before we even get into
that like how do we get to this point
where chicken is like overwhelmingly
then
per one animal product in the United
States unfortunately the animal the
chicken lends itself to the industrial
setting and sir has is is a victim of
its survivability of her his or her
survivability so they're they're able to
grow through selective breeding very
fast very large birds so the birds we
eat are forty to forty five days old
babies they're obese babies and they can
do a ton of them in these warehouses
these darkened warehouses all in a row
thirty thousand birds in a house a
typical farm has two to four of these
houses and they're doing that five or
six times a year so this it was just
more scalable than anything else yeah I
think I read that if it was a human so
how old are the chicks when they're
slaughtered about forty two days forty
two days right so if it was a human baby
that baby it would be the equivalent of
like blowing up a human baby to like six
hundred pounds by the time they're like
six months or two years old yeah it's
insane
the yeah so like how we breed dogs for
qualities that we like in dogs they did
the same with with the birds so and the
thing that they bred for was giant
breasts because that's what we like to
eat that's the kind of part that people
enjoy eating and everything else was an
unintended consequence so we selectively
bred these birds till they were bigger
and bigger and bigger and bigger and
grew faster and faster and faster but
their lungs and their heart did not get
selectively bred for and they can't keep
up with the muscular skeletal demands of
these strange Franken chickens they
collapse under their own weight three
percent when they get to only for forty
days of age can't even walk and about a
quarter of them have great difficulty
walking and I've seen the birds so
sometimes birds fall off of trucks and
people will adopt them and try to get
them better
they'd never live beyond six or nine
months because they die of heart attacks
they look like turkeys they're just
abnormal and the industry has created a
bird that
they only want to survive 240 days and
they can't even do that so there's in a
flock of thirty thousand birds in one of
these warehouses about 1500 of them are
guaranteed to die they won't make it
about five percent yeah so when you make
this video with Craig which we're gonna
get into I mean one of the shocking
things is first of all like he has to
kill so many you know there's so many
sick ones but then because they can't
support their own weight they're just
they're lying on their stomachs and kind
of shuffling around they get chafed and
all the feathers are rubbed off their
belly and they have these open sores all
over them yeah yeah and and those are
the considered that's like normal those
are the ones we and that's some very
normal so the a lot of people think I
remember talking to my mom about this
and trying and telling her like this is
how it is and she said well they they
changed the the litter right like every
day or so like a birdcage and I was like
mom no they never changed the litter
many many flocks live and poop and die
on that litter that's on the bottom so
we're talking about like wood shavings
that are mixed with like feed and feces
and what they do is they're living on a
composting bed of stuff of feed and
shavings and feces and feathers and all
kinds of other things and that starts to
compost and heat up and when I was with
Craig at one point asked him for a
thermometer and I put the thermometer in
the the bedding and it was about 87
degrees so then on top so the chickens
are sitting on top of an 87 degree bed
of bacterially decomposing stuff and
they can't get up and then there's and
they're also stuffed wall-to-wall so
every time one of them moves it's shift
shift shift shift shift shift shift
shift shift shift so there that's
happening all day this slight rubbing of
their chests on hot litter and they
can't get up very easily they get up
very with great difficulty to get food
and water and then they sit back down
and so the rubbing becomes constant and
I I don't I don't know why but I had
this impulse to pick one up and look at
her and it was a raw
red-belly with sores and easily where
bacteria can enter where there they
definitely are feeling sick and hot and
uncomfortable and in pain and then they
take that run off and then they just
spray it on the fields right yeah and it
gets it becomes almost like an aerosol
it's in the air well maybe that's more
pigs you're thinking I'm thinking of
this scene in conspiracy where they're
spraying that and that's moisture
surrounding you know families are like
inhaling this stuff yeah the pig the pig
manures are the manure lagoons I don't
know why they call it that like it's
something beautiful and like you pull a
beach chair up to relax but they call
them manure lagoons and they are lagoons
next to big pig factory farms and that's
just liquid slosh going into a pool and
then they don't have a way to deal with
that so they spray it onto our crops and
onto our fields which is when you have a
lettuce outbreak of e.coli
it's not because lettuce produces e.coli
it's because that lettuce has been
sprayed with feces from a farmed animal
that's so disturbing that's horrible
but with the chickens they so they don't
do that with the the chicken manure it
stays there they tend to compost it so
they what they do is after each flock
clears out and goes to slaughter they
push it all into the middle they take
the cake it there's a cake on the top
and they take the cake off and then they
put that aside into a kind of pile that
they're composting out then they put it
in the middle they let it get really
really hot in the compost and then they
spread it back out and they say oh
that's really good it kills the bacteria
and all of that and then they put new
chickens on that same right that same
well looking at at how this has scaled
up like you're talking about how it was
you know it was the animal that lent
itself to be able to be vertically
integrated in that way but at the same
time there has to be a corresponding
consumer demand
so I would imagine these things you know
dovetail with this idea of chicken being
a healthier alternative to beef and pork
right where suddenly people are like
getting off the red meat but eating more
and more chicken yeah and in no way do I
want to blame the animal for like saying
that they lend themself I'm yeah I want
to be good right yeah thank you I think
I'm not implying that no I think I said
that and I realize it's you know it was
an unfortunate result of them being able
to survive horrible circumstances but
yeah one of the big shifts that happened
is the Nugget the chicken nugget that
McDonald's created and this shifted the
convenience factor of eating animals
where before it was on a bone and it had
to be produced like whole chickens were
chicken used to be something that we ate
on a Sunday as a roast and we roasted
the whole chicken it was special and we
ate the whole thing
and then the Nugget came around and that
was a McDonald's invention and this
changed the landscape for how chicken
could be produced it drove that white
meat that breast meat demand and that
changed a lot and the other factor was
you know KFC doing the fried chicken
buckets like being able to bread and fry
it and these deep fryers that allowed
for the convenience factors the
fast-food industry had a lot to do with
the explosion of chicken and then people
demanding and wanting this convenient
fast food and that that really changed
things right we've all seen the pink
sludge videos of how McNuggets get made
I mean is it they just take all parts of
the chicken and grind it up like how
does that work well it depends because
after that pink sludge video companies
changed their tune a little bit and so
some companies say they don't do that
and they mostly use white meat and
you'll see you know we use 100% breast
meat and but a lot of nuggets you don't
know what's in there you know it's like
a hot dog he also don't know what's in
there on top of that chickens suffer
from speciesism you know because
you know we you know we love our dogs
and if you spend any time with cows or
pigs you can see their you know inner
personalities and and their character
and you understand that they have
empathy and feelings and they experience
joy and pain and suffering and all of
these things but human beings have a
harder time identifying with poultry in
the same way yeah and you know getting
back to our first part of our
conversation I because I had this first
you know hand encounter with ducks I
knew them I had looked into all of their
eyes and maybe had this this sense of
their sentience more than the average
person because of this firsthand
knowledge were you talk in the book
about some crazy superpowers that
chickens have that I did not know about
so I explained that well they can see
colors that we can't see which blows my
mind I saw an advertisement the other
day like is there a color you haven't
seen and I was like chickens have
chickens chickens have seen colors you
haven't seen and they can see far away
and close at the same time or as we have
to do one or the other mm-hmm which is
why they can spot you know a bug in the
grass and move for it real quick which
you know I think I often my joke is I
can't even fill my keys most morning
right there's no way but the coolest
thing I think they do is they can orient
themselves in a magnetic field of the
planet which is a trap that's real what
does that mean they can we need a
compass to tell us which way is north
and they don't essentially and they can
sense direction and find places without
without Google Maps right
what about joy and you know a sense of
belonging to a community like all of
these you know anthropomorphic
experiences that we think are innately
human like what is the what is the
chicken experience yeah and I talk about
this a lot in my book this site
of anthropomorphism being bad or that
we've been and I feel like that concept
is really being rejected because it
assumes that humans aren't animals and
of course we are and therefore these are
degrees of differences not not kinds
we're not we've evolved with emotions
and therefore they have emotions too and
these help them in social settings so
any animal that needs to communicate to
survive they're going to need to have
things like empathy and to understand if
their fellow flock mate is suffering and
there have been some really great
studies like Joanna Edgar from
University of Bristol did a really great
study to show that mother hens have the
ability of this empathy of empathy and
what she did is she did these puffs of
air on the chicks on the babies and that
they would be very distressed the babies
didn't like the puffs of air in their
face didn't enjoy that and then the
mothers would have a reaction to that
and then it became very clear that just
by showing the the device that the
mother would start getting agitated like
and when I was with as recline came up
with a great analogy of like it's like
when you see your kid about to get a
shot and your heart your heartbeat goes
up it's the same thing this is empathy
this is your ability to understand the
suffering of another which we often
think is our unique skill right and on
the same you know on the same on the
flip side of that coin if you can have
empathy if you can have sadness if
you're suffering of course you can have
joy of course and for a long time animal
welfare study just studies just looked
at suffering and pain and more recently
they're like well the other side of that
is joy yeah and animals can also have
joy and our objective should be if we're
gonna eat or raise animals is to give
them lives worth living where they get
to enjoy themselves and that's very
controversial of quote we also don't we
don't really want to believe that right
like the other thing that Ezra pointed
out is like oh I feel like like he
started to tense up like I he had this
sense that
everybody's gonna start tuning out right
because it's like we clutch up when we
start hearing this because we're on the
receiving end of information that is it
odds with our you know 1/8
you know the compassion that is innate
to all human beings and we don't like
the idea that we're making choices that
that contravene our inherent value
systems yeah is it's a very hard one to
navigate because essentially because the
vegan-vegetarian it's about five six
percent of the population essentially
everyone is engaging in this behavior
everyone is allowing this to happen and
is part of it and paying for it and
that's a really hard discussion to have
it's very hard to have it with your
friends you like and you care about and
they're progressive and they're good
people and it's hard to navigate a world
like that yeah because the minute you
bring it up there's a sense of
defensiveness or a feeling that somebody
is being you know personally assailed or
attacked for yeah and choices and you
know it quickly becomes uncomfortable
yeah and over the years I I swing
between my main way of behaving is the
way I behave with these companies which
is I'm just trying to find one step
forward because one step forward means a
lot less suffering so even with friends
family any discussion I have it's not go
vegan all or nothing like a light switch
it's a conversation about what can you
do what could be your next step well it
feels like cultural awareness is at an
all-time high in terms of you know
people being open to these ideas making
personal changes in their own lives like
everywhere you go there's vegan options
there fast food industry which we're
going to get into is is really you know
moving in the right direction in terms
of providing alternative you know
plant-based options and yet at the same
time like the meat the meat consumption
is also at an all-time high right like
there's this kind of you know arms race
going on
total names it is so you know we're
talking the weekend of Super Bowl Sunday
on Sunday and one point four billion
Wings will be eaten on Sunday just in
one day at one one day that's you know
700 million birds right I think you say
in the book like if you were to put line
them up and and it would go across the
globe a couple times three times it's
and this is I in that stat I get from
the National chicken Council website
where they are advocating they're very
proud they're like some Sunday is a
national holiday where we should be
called national wing day you know
because so well yes there's awesome
things happening like the impossible
burger at Burger King or all of these
products young meat at Carl's jr. right
you know yeah I mean there's it's KFC is
doing a pilot program right now right
and you did something with Popeyes
reasons yes that was so fun that that
made that was a happy day for me yeah so
in Atlanta they they trialed the beyond
chicken nugget and they it was one day
only and we got the notice from beyond
meat the night before their like get
there we'll have you press with you and
you can do a whole video on it I get
there at 10 o'clock when it opens and
there's like lines wrapped around the
corner the trap they have police like
directing traffic they've painted the
KFC green like lime green I saw that it
was insane you would think they were
giving out free beyoncé tickets writing
it was it's so interesting that that
that's happening I mean who would have
predicted that that's crazy so clear
like I think was it was a Burger King
that said their launch was like them
it's like the most successful like new
product launch that they've had and you
know decades or something else bringing
customers back to an industry that if it
would have gone the way of the dinosaurs
like it was on its way out right and
there this is the argument that we make
about plant-based products is look at
the demand people are ready for this
shift they want it meet them or you're
gonna go out of business
mmm-hmm because people are gonna find
another way they're gonna move away from
this right I think it's such an
important message and I get disheartened
when I see
think there was the you saw that like
somebody sued Burger King because their
their their burger was cooked on the
same grill as meat products or what I
feel like things like that are
counterproductive to the broader mission
of what I think we can all agree we're
trying to accomplish here yeah and it's
not for vegans right it's yeah you're
that burger is not for that guy he
should be doing his own thing right
burger king like these offerings are for
the meat eater yeah
I can't tell you how often I get like a
text from somebody who was like hey I
was in the middle nowhere and I got the
beyond sausage at Dunkin Donuts it was
good I'm gonna get it again my cousin
who's like he's in the Marines you know
not the kind of guy you would think who
would be interested in vegan products at
all he wrote me the other day I tried
the impossible burger burger he was
actually good what's in it yeah you know
it's it's it is an important I feel like
we are at the initial stages of a real
protein revolution where we totally
reframe our concept of where protein
comes from and what it constitutes and
these moments while not significant
relief in the moment for farmed animals
because it's not affecting that many
animals are the precursor to our total
paradigm shift yeah and the smart move
and this is something that you're very
involved in that we're gonna talk about
the smart move if you're sitting on the
throne at the purdue's and the Tyson's
and all of these gigantic animal
agriculture conglomerates is to shift
your business plan away from this
unsustainable protein source that's
creating all of these problems and also
requires an unbelievable amount of land
and resources and creates environmental
havoc and untold amounts of suffering to
these plant-based alternatives that are
very much the future and you know also
you know look better on the on the PNA
the PNL right right like they make more
sense and this is where the consumer
demand you know is is leading them so
either get on board with that and
survive and innovate for the future or I
think these other companies that are
that
kind of recalcitrant or reluctant to do
that or gonna go the way of the dodo
right and you know the the thing that
happened with Craig where I look I
started to look for the win-win instead
of just trying to destroy him that
started to happen with companies too in
our movement more widely and the idea
was instead of trying to put these
companies out of business let's try to
help them evolve into the business we do
want right because they already have all
the machines they have all of the bram
they have the money if they get on board
it's going to accelerate that's how you
shift everything right so just walking
us up to that point
Craig ultimately takes you on to the
into the you know into the chicken farms
you're able to film all of this and you
put a video out and you're able to get
Nick Kristof at the New York Times to
you know kind of align himself with what
you guys are doing and he ends up
writing two op-ed pieces right which
really you know kind of blow things wide
open yeah he he wrote this op-ed and
we're watching the video numbers and in
24 hours it was a million views it was
insane never expected it people were so
upset about what was happening and as I
said this was a unique moment because it
had been so long since we had seen
inside of a factory farm where chickens
are being raised and not only that this
was not grainy undercover footage these
were professional filmmaking cameras
they were catching the real up-close
suffering of these birds and then the
suffering of this man and then the
tricking and hoodwinking of this company
and then these two unlikely advocates
working together it was a very powerful
story that really spoke to people that
it had to be true that this was not okay
and this really put the put chickens on
the map in terms of this is a problem we
have to solve and that began a lot of
organizations working on that and moving
toward what we now are we have a
coalition campaign to change the way
that chickens are raised in this country
but initially the in reaction to the
first piece the Purdue response was to
point the finger at Craig and say that
he's mismanaging this is his fault
this is not you know we don't this is
not about us and that really backfired
because the public's all right through
that yeah I mean the first thing they
did was send out these sort of Purdue
police to come out and you know write
him up and say you're a bad farmer and
then they said you can't have any more
chickens so we're not gonna pay you and
tell you yeah you retrain on animal
welfare which was clearly a reach out to
get him in line right it was a
retaliatory behavior and so I had hooked
him up with Amanda hit who is an
attorney and he had pro bono legal
counsel from her and they count they did
a lawsuit a protective lawsuit in which
they sued Purdue for that and the public
were you know what kept happening is
Purdue wanted to act like nothing had
happened so they would put up on there
we were monitoring their Facebook site
and they would put up like oh here's a
great new recipe for chicken and then
people be like what's wrong with you
later boy this is happening right now
stop talking about recipes and what are
you doing about this and and they
wouldn't respond in any way but people
were relentless and these were not
people Mercy for Animals or any group or
putting up to doing just average
consumers yeah it really reached people
and I you know I that speaks to my core
belief that if people knew if they
really really if it got through to them
I got through all the noise that is in
our world it wouldn't be like this and
that really drives me and many advocates
so how do you how did you go from that
moment to the relationship that you have
with Jim Purdue today and the changes
that they've I mean they to their credit
like they've really changed they have
they have and so for about a year they
totally wouldn't did he Stonewall me
they would not speak to me and then I
remember reading an article again in The
New York Times about how around
antibiotics and Purdue and at the very
very end of the article it said that
Purdue had sent someone named Bruce
Stewart Brown over to the UK to look at
what chickens need and want and then
Jim Perdue saying we need happier birds
which was a very strange statement
coming from a chicken company so I I
knew that when you're when this article
was referring to needs and once they
were referring to a framework by a
veterinarian called her name is Marian
Dawkins who is one of the leaders in
chicken welfare in the UK so I knew they
were talking to her and that was a good
thing they knew they must be talking
about how to change their practices and
at the time Mercy for Animals had come
up with two maybe three undercover
investigations in on farms showing them
like again and again you're still not
okay and I wrote to their PR person and
said a very like emotional raw letter
saying I don't think we're that far
apart on this can we talk please can I
talk to Bruce can I talk to him bout
what he's learning I think there may be
more in common than we realized
simultaneously mark McKay at the company
who's now the president he said when
they got the Mercy for Animals footage
they all looked at it and were horrified
and they all said does anybody think
this is okay no has anybody talked to
Mercy for Animals no we need to talk to
them we need to talk to these advocates
and they took me up on the offer and
that's when things started to turn
around and I did a meet Jim Purdue until
a good few months later and I didn't
know why I was gonna meet him when I met
him and they decided to bring me on a
tour of their facilities and when I kind
of came down the stairs there he was
like right I had no idea he was a first
of all when they invite you to come over
for a tour what's going on in your head
like how is this gonna go again I don't
know why I'm invited and I don't know
what's going on but I say yes anyway and
that seems to be the standard in my life
where I just go with it and see what
happens and so what happens with him
when you meet him he was really kind and
very human and he I had you know he
asked me about myself and I had missed
something some invitation earlier and it
was
I was adopting my daughter and he
remembered that and it just showed a
real human side of him that I hadn't not
expected and I know the difference like
I have met many many poultry executives
or food executives who are they hate me
they see me walk in the door and the
body language just says I don't want to
talk to you like there's no opening here
but Jim Perdue was was his energy said
I'm open like I would this is something
I genuinely want to talk about and to
produce credit they've made a lot of
progress and I do believe it's because
Jim Perdue honestly remembers his
grandfather's way of raising things he
remembers a time when chickens were
outside and free-range and today 25% of
produced chickens are actually
free-range outside access and they've
shift that's a rapid shift from when we
started right the one of the big changes
was putting windows on all of these
housing facilities for the chickens
right and that that's really important
for the chickens to experience the you
know day and night differences and
getting six hours of consistent sleep
normally in the industry they might get
an hour where the lights are turned off
and they want to keep them awake and the
lights on not too bright so they're
constantly eating so they're getting fat
faster but also simultaneously investing
in plant-based alternatives right right
he said something like you know we're a
protein company we're not a meat protein
company yeah I mean that's like a that's
a big statement for it's showing Heat
somebody like that he said we went to
they now hold these annual summits where
they bring stakeholders together and
their customers together and I've gone
to five of them now and at one of them
they asked me I go on a stage and they
it's like a QA and they're like okay
here's your you get to say anything to
us what are you going to say and I said
you need to explore moving into the
plant-based direction it you know you're
you're not going to be able to afford so
raising chickens and this way costs more
money and therefore people are going to
eat less of it because the most the
driving reason for purchasing chicken is
because it's
and as the price goes up so we're gonna
eat less of it which is a good thing so
if you want to keep your business going
why don't you explore some plant-based
even do blended even do half chicken
half and move in that direction half
plans and within six months of a
conversation so then I was in line with
him and he said huh well you know
nothing about our brand says that we're
premium protein brand doesn't say
anything about premium chicken brand so
if that's where consumers are going we
can follow that and then he made an
actual announcement later and to a
newspaper or to Bloomberg and talked
about that that's a seismic change from
where we started where they were
defending that this horrible practice
was humanely raised and they had a
controversial label that was tricking
consumers to saying hey maybe we will
try out plant-based the arc of that
journey to me it was the one I just
never would have expected but on the
subject of being controversial to some
that move you know your moves would be
considered controversial like I'm
certain there's a wing of the animal
rights movement that isn't happy with
all of this collaboration right there's
a tension between cooperation and this
you know Avenue that you're devoted to
pursuing and complicity right so how do
you like you know reckon with those two
worlds yeah and this concept of
engagement doesn't mean endorsement and
for me the driving factor is my job on
this planet while I'm here is to reduce
suffering of these farmed animals and
while I would like there to be some kind
of secret on/off switch that I can just
make everybody vegan that's not
happening tomorrow
and so my job in the meantime as we move
towards that world is to reduce the
suffering of the eighty billion farmed
animals that are raised in slaughter
every year in this world right let's
focus on the real the big problem yeah
and the analogy I often use because I
get this a lot this it's the main it's
just some people it's why my approach is
unacceptable because they want the on
off they just want and I get it I want
that too I really do but the analogy I
use is
you're a prisoner in a horrible prison
on death row would you just want someone
advocating to end the death penalty
penalty only or doing end the death
penalty and improve my prison conditions
you would want both and that's what the
animals want from us the one that's
stuck today in the factory farm they're
never going to see the benefit of the
vegan world so today we need to help
them and there is no evidence that in
doing that we are getting people to eat
more meat in fact there is the opposite
evidence because the price goes up that
is the driving factor when we improve
the conditions of the animals or we do
reduce their suffering it means in that
square box they're being raised in it's
less economical you can raise less
animals those animals cost more to the
consumer and people buy less they buy up
based on price it's the main thing
people buy on is the cheapness right how
do you government subsidies work with
chicken
well the biggest factor is the feed so
soy and corn are the biggest factor
affecting chicken prices and the
subsidies related to that or what drive
the cheap chicken prices and if we could
somehow impact that we would be in a
whole nother economic situation I think
the other big Avenue to pursue and I
know you're already doing this is is to
help these farmers find different ways
of using their land that are more
economically viable and free them up
from this indentured servitude
death structure so talk to me about you
started this new initiative called
what's it called trans transformation
right and I think this is super cool
like there's the example of this one guy
who basically switched his chicken farm
into a hemp farm right I would imagine
that if you can provide these farmers
and it's and create the incentives and
make it I know there's like a lot of
barriers and it's very difficult to do
this but to create an incentive
structure that makes this not just
feasible but more beneficial for them
that that would be you know a massive
way to influence this whole thing yeah
my my
strong belief in terms of theories of
change is we can't just be destructive
forces in the world so as advocates we
can't just come in and say destroy
factory farming we have to construct
something better we have to come in and
be constructive forces so transformation
is a constructive force it is where we
are coming in and saying instead of
doing this the farmer is the enemy okay
the farmer is now our partner the farmer
can be our partner and that's the
win-win and that's the kind of when I
say we want to create a compassionate
food system for everyone I mean that
farmer to and this transformation idea
is to get farmers who are raising
chickens in warehouses to then transform
transform into hemp hydroponic lettuce
mint basil any of these kinds of options
and there are farmers doing the the the
when we we put out this project we were
kind of shaking the tree to see what was
in there and see what fell out and
there's a lot of people doing this
already so we just discovered a farmer
in Harrisburg Pennsylvania
they were chicken farmers and now
they're doing hydroponic basil and
peppermint and they did it on their own
they just and there's farm and they want
more yeah when I do it and and really
meet their revenue needs more than Wow
more than because that the system of
chicken factory form does not benefit a
farmer like I said they're making five
cents a pound on a bird with an
astronomical debt they can never get out
of the the trouble is finding for us
right now we're we launched this project
in November the challenge is that debt
is that fight you gotta get out of that
first before you can even have that and
that's gonna take policy change and so
Cory Booker just put out a new
initiative to ban factory farming by
2040 and a part of that is a federal
fund for debt forgiveness for these
farmers and yeah and it's it's the right
amount to get farmers out of this and
that's what we're gonna need we need
some kind of debt forgiveness for these
farmers to move away from this system
and I'm
really excited that this conversation is
starting to happen the time has come for
this initiative and I when I see Cory
Booker coming out with something like
that and I see a farmer who's doing it
on his own
it feels really hopeful to me I would
imagine you know the psychological
burden or trauma that a lot of these
farmers you know whether as a result of
you know raising these chickens and
having to kill so many in just the
conditions of all of it that it would be
you know such a relief to be able to not
have to do that I mean what is your
sense of the toll that they pay you know
emotionally really but it's it's not
good we we have this through
transformation we have a way farmers can
get in touch with us and tell us their
story and we're trying to find the right
combination of lower debt and ability to
speak out to become part of our
transformation project our goal is to
start with a small group and connect
them with businesses that plant based
businesses that want to help them
transform so through this we're hearing
a lot of stories and talking to farmers
who talk about the sadness
one farmer referred to himself as a mass
murderer and he felt there's nothing he
could do about it did this was his job
and when I followed Craig around his job
was to pick up dead and dying birds and
to dislocate their necks and he did that
every flock every house about 1,500
Birds over 40 day period
that's his basic job and then make sure
the computers are running that's it and
that's a horrible job it's a horrible
job that nobody should have to do and
we're kind of paying someone else to do
that that's what I hate about it most is
consumers I and I struggle some days
where I'm sitting in the airport and I'm
watching everyone around me tear into
their chicken and I'm thinking back and
back and back and back to where that
chicken came from came from and they are
not mm-hmm and it's yeah well it's that
gap between information and action it's
not about facts and information no no I
I would imagine most of those people if
you if you pin them down
said do you know where this come from
they they might they very well may be
able to tell you yeah but there's still
you know a big difference between that
awareness and yeah and actually behavior
modification yeah and I've gone through
different phases of activism where I
just think if only people knew enough
and then there's not about the no right
and then they know and then I'm super
angry because I know everybody knows and
they're still doing it and then the
point where I'm more at now most days is
it just progress is all that matters
reducing suffering is all that matters
how it whatever it takes to get the
person there whether it be I'm gonna
raise the price of chicken and then
you're not gonna eat it as much you
don't even care and never will where it
comes from or you know making it unlike
at was saying this is unhealthy the USDA
is not covering it anymore or making
this other product seem more exciting
and trendy like plant-based KFC nugget
how do you take care of yourself in all
of this and not get burned out or
despondent when you're kind of on the
frontlines of this it's very emotional
all of it yeah it takes a lot of work
especially being in leadership and
having to lead teams through essentially
we are witnessing trauma we're
witnessing we are bearing witness to
suffering as that's what we do for a
living
bearing witness to suffering and then
putting it into a megaphone and shooting
it out into the world hoping for
improvement and I was really great about
it for a long long time and then over
the last year it caught up with me
somehow and I think it was a combination
you know I I turned 40 and like really
realized I could be a midway point and
what have I done and will it stop and
really realizing for all of my
fast-moving it's still really slow and
feeling really down and frustrated about
that and I read a great you know I went
to a therapist for the first time and
was I had found that I would I
realizes I had totally gone into work
only all the time had really almost
removed myself from all social settings
because I couldn't I just get angry at
people and I just never enjoy myself I
remember sitting with a bunch of friends
and going out to dinner with them and a
farm-to-table restaurant and they were
discussing whether or not to order
octopus and I had to go to the bathroom
and I like and I almost walked down
these are my good friends and you know I
know they get anything about
environmental sustainability while
eating yeah the merits of eating octopus
and all I'm thinking of this awesome
book I read about how smart octopus are
and how cool they are and why would you
eat them and I just like you know and
realizing I'm not in a healthy place
because I could do this before and I
could have had a conversation but it
adds up it it's secondary trauma there's
a great book called trauma stewardship
which is about realizing four it was
it's really written for anybody who
works in spaces where you're bearing
witness is suffering so it's also people
who work in the ER room or social
workers or witnessing abuse of children
or women and how to cope with that
because you're not you can't just turn
it off you can't it's in you it's part
of you and what you have to do is take
care of yourself and as and do self-care
which is not something advocates allow
themselves to do right because you're an
automatic the works never done the work
so there's a there's there's this guilt
and this sensitivity yeah and this sense
that well the minute you take your foot
off the pedal another harm is taking
place that perhaps you could have done
something about and you could you can
drive yourself to insanity I would
imagine yeah and the most significant
part of that is you think my suffering
is insignificant in comparison but
compassion begins with the self right
you have to have compassion for you for
yourself especially if you want to
sustain your advocacy over time right
and I for some reason had been great
about that somehow balancing all of that
but in the last year it caught up to me
and I realized I had seen just so much
suffering I'd witnessed
that the undercover investigations and
the slow-moving change and feeling very
frustrated and focusing on the negative
than the positive and as a result
withdrawing from a lot of social any
kind of you know social gatherings not
wanting to do Christmas or Thanksgiving
or anything you know haven't really what
happened was I lost the ability she'd be
joyful in my life and I had to work on
that yeah then you're no good to nobody
right and that's not very much yourself
either
that's not nobody wants to boss but you
know what's interesting is it also works
conversely like I was very I said this
to you in an email but I was very moved
by Joaquin Phoenix's speech at the
Golden Globes and I think he won the
same award at like the SAG Awards a
couple weeks later and right after
winning that award at that fancy event
he went straight to the pig vigil in his
fancy tuxedo it's almost as if he needed
that counterbalance right as a dose of
humility or to remind himself of what's
most important to him because you know
the rest is ego and it's illusion right
that makes you feel like something that
isn't you know really tangible right and
it was like he it was like in order for
him to ground himself and be who he
really is or remind himself of what his
values are he had to show up there and
he didn't even take a moment to change
he went straight there I just thought
that was like such a beautiful and
powerful symbolic gesture and I know he
goes to those all the time it's not like
it wasn't it wasn't it wasn't a symbolic
thing because this is what he does yeah
but it's almost as if it works in
Reverse as it does for you like he he
has to make sure that he's plugged into
that right so that he can be his best
self right right and for me I'm trying
to plug back into what makes me joyful
so that I can be present for my kids who
are growing fast is your 24/7 on this
right it's never
not part of how I'm looking at the world
it's my filter and so for me it was
trying to identify the areas that help
me feel joyful and that helps me be a
more creative and innovative advocate
right which is critical like the
transformation idea came from a idea
period in my life when I was feeling
really energized and joyful that idea
came from that period of feeling hopeful
and joyful about the world and if you
don't find that if you lose that I think
you lose a lot of the solutions that you
need to solve hard-nosed how has it been
going from you know being sort of like a
DIY rogue you know agent who this
movement to now running Mercy for
Animals I mean you know you're
shouldering a lot of responsibility and
you're you know a lot of people that may
have had something to do with me having
like a little meltdown okay it's a lot
it's a lot it's a lot of that now it's
not just the issue it's like it's
managing people and yeah projects and
yeah and it's being in the spotlight you
know which there's a face yeah and that
was like what the as you were saying
like the ego it's like having to kind of
let go realize there's gonna be this
person that people think you are in the
public and then the person you just have
to hold on to and separate yourself from
that and that managing an organization
this large of now this is not like a
corporation right these are this is a
bunch of warriors a bunch of advocates
who are here because they're we get
every job we get hundreds of applicants
so these are the best of the best of the
best of the best people in the
organization who are here because they
believe in this cause and they have the
skills to do it
they have the passion so these are
people they don't like to be managed
like these are advocates and if I don't
you know figure out how to respect them
and give them an environment in which
they can thrive they're there
campaigners they know to get rid of me
you know this is like a collaboration
also it's your job to put the guardrails
up right exactly and my job is to direct
like the road and
we created it right out of the gate I
created a three-year strategy to say
these are our priorities this is a big
problem let's let's let's drive it into
this we're gonna go down this highway
and see the progress we make and work
together on that and we created that
that strategy together and that felt
really good because people had a say in
it and they were part of it
but you know I feel like my job is to
create an environment in which all these
warriors can thrive and be their best
self for animals and that's a great
privilege like I get to my actual job
when I'm feeling good about it is to get
up every day and hope farmed animals and
help people help farmed animals and
that's that's fantastic yeah I mean you
are an optimistic person yes yes
ultimately I am an optimistic person and
the book you know kind of the latter
parts of the book are about that
optimism and what we're seeing right now
with the beyond meets and the impossible
burgers and the good food Institute and
the work that Bruce and his team are
doing and Memphis meets and the cell
based alternatives like there's you know
it's exciting times it is a great time
to be alive it's you know we haven't had
factory farming and this way of eating
animals around for very long it's only
been 70 years you know since that's
crazy it is it's world war two is when
we made the switch it's really when we
put in the subsidies that allowed for
the rapid growth of factory farming and
consumption of meat and I believe we can
undo it just as fast if not faster if
you think about technology and bringing
in things like Memphis meat just last
week got an injection of a hundred and
sixty-one million dollars for their
series B which is a for those who don't
know Memphis meat they are about growing
cellular meat so I think we're calling
it cultivated meat now and terms keep
change I know they do I'm trying to keep
a ceccolini ruing it they're brewing
themselves into Nuggets and burgers so
that no animal is slaughtered ever and
you don't use all the resources you're
just growing the parts that we eat and
it has all the same components as the
actual burger or whatever it is that you
want to eat so that's what I think we
need for this rapid change and I think I
have personally had the opportunity to
try cellular me yeah I was gonna ask
yeah have you tried it no I haven't I
know uma I keep bugging him to come on
the podcast yeah he's not ready to but
ya know I haven't tried it yet yeah so I
I don't know if I want
I didn't he doesn't want to I know I
it's not I'm not the I'm not the
customer for it
we're not the guy suppose I asked Bruce
Friedrich of course he you know like he
Paul Shapiro also like you know you kind
of have to I suppose yeah I went in you
know in the Bay Area and there was a
company there's company called mission
barns there's like 30 companies around
us right and that's happened really fast
that's happened in five years right and
lesson and they had duck sausage and to
me this was like the full circle of my
journey right all the way back right
till the doctor Florida house like I you
know I would never eat duck underneath
my er right and this is doc so you know
when I bit into that sausage I didn't
know if I was gonna do it and I didn't
even know when I got there they're gonna
offer it to me and I was just wanted to
see the lab and here talk to the
scientist and talk to them for my book
about their their vision and they said
oh we just had a testing last night for
some of our investors we have a few
sausages left you want to try it okay
and it was a mushroom duck sausage and I
did it and I bit into it and it felt
like the future it felt it was such a
euphoric moment for me because it in
that bite it was all things that are
possible like the end of factory farming
the end of torturing animals for protein
wasn't that bite to me and I was so
happy to be alive for this moment I I
know that it's happening and when you
think of technological changes that have
happened in the last 10 years imagine
what's gonna happen in the next it just
it blows it wide open you know and for
people that are listening this is not a
plant-based version of duck sausage this
is legitimate duck meat cells grown in a
in a you know fermented way like this
proprietary way but it's basically it is
meat yeah my imagination out the scent
right the animal is never slaughtered
and so the just the company that does
the Mayo and the egg they're also
exploring or they're doing this now too
right and they put out a great video
that I felt really explained how
exciting and strange this is like the
stuff of sci-fi for it was called Ian
the chicken and they had this farmer say
this is Ian and you think maybe this
slaughter this chickens about to be
slaughtered or something like what's
happening it's like a farm-to-table
situation maybe and he has a feather
from Ian he's like this is Ian's feather
and then it goes into breaking down the
components of the feather into the
cellular level taking out the stem cells
of this you know the the cells that can
grow into anything and growing that in
in the lab and then next shot is them
eating this chicken nugget made out of
eeehm cells as iam is walking around
next to them and it well it's yeah it's
bizarre I mean I think there is there
will certainly be a consumer adoption
period phase because there's there's a
there's a lot of bristling like oh this
isn't natural truly what's not natural I
mean go to a slaughterhouse that's not
natural like there's nothing natural
about that there's nothing natural about
moving down a highway at 80 miles an
hour either you know and this is I think
unanimously you know anybody who knows
anything about factory farming is is is
appalled by it it's an abhorrent system
and to the extent that we can do away
with it I think I think public sentiment
would be completely on board with that
and when the Memphis meats of the world
figure out how to create these things at
scale at an affordable price point it's
going to be game over yeah I have every
faith that the public will fully adopt
this once the price point is right and
like I said all of the marketing
research is people buy on price that's
the fun that's the main thing so the
taste yeah just as good if not better
convenience price and taste are the
three factors that we
have to meet if we're gonna compete with
meat and I think that if you're
essentially if you're producing the same
product the taste is gonna be the same
so these are just cells made into the
same thing so that's gonna be about
convenience and it's gonna be all price
and that's tough but it will happen
because if you think of things like the
flat-screen TV right that at one point
was thousands of dollars now is in
everybody's home you you can purchase it
easily or the car like all of the
technological advances the phones we
have all of them the prices start off
ridiculous mm-hmm and then they come
right down and then every day first as
low as $200,000 and now you know there's
model threes all over the place I mean
this is the way this stuff works exactly
and it's super exciting yeah yeah I mean
it's it's a crazy future I mean I
wouldn't have thought you think flying
cars but you didn't no one thought like
how food this way so it's super
interesting I mean if I was Jim Purdue I
would have written the hundred million
dollar check to you know send a memphis
meets I hope they will one day you know
I think they should do it themselves and
I've definitely told that to them I
think they should be investing in clean
meat cultivated meat
I think they should you know be
investing in this world because it is
the way of the future and it's the the
most wonderful part about it is that it
doesn't just stop all that suffering it
saves our species it saves our planet
and that's that's such a exciting thing
because on the flip side you see
everything that's happening on climate
change and it causes widespread panic
you know there's just this panic feeling
and our kids growing up where the
climate change is just a part of the
reality I've never known a time my kids
when we're not talking about the
catastrophic trajectory we're on as a
planet and my hope is a technology like
this is going to come in and take out a
big factor it's going to take out
factory farming and your advocacy
continues to be important because we
have to pass the laws we have to educate
people we have to raise public awareness
to drive these technological advances
faster and ensure that the trajectories
progress won't happen on its own we have
to be there to push it and pull it and
fight for it as well yeah I think we
need we need policy
Changez and like I said earlier
incentive incentivization programs for
these farmers you got to take care of
these farmers and figure out a way
forward for them so that they can
transcend this system that they're in
and make use of their land in a more
productive environmentally conscious
sustainable and compassionate way yeah
and I I think when I think of the why
this could happen faster in the
relationship between you know animal
rights advocacy and these technologies
and these advances and the farmers I
can't think of many other products like
the beyond product or the impossible
where you have like an army of advocates
saying we want this to win and you know
putting it all out in their instagrams
and all their social media channels and
doing videos and in droves going to
support a product to succeed for social
justice consumers yet they become their
like fans yeah they're like fans and I
think that you know you think of the IPO
of beyond being so successful this year
well there was an army of advocates that
got read the market really excited about
this and that's where the relationship
between the animal advocates the
technology and the market will drive
this change fast if we collaborate if we
get it right if we get that formula
right right
what's going on with McDonald's welcome
to all these other all the other
franchises happen on board they seem to
be talked about patients yeah I know
they're dancing around it they're
thinking about it but they haven't
actually offered a product yet I think
they did a small pilot right but in
Canada is that what it was yeah and I
mean McDonald's is behind the times and
they're suffering for it and they will
continue to suffer if not go out of
business if they're not careful so we
have a big campaign we've been running
with the coalition on chickens and the
way they treat their chickens and it's
the better chicken commitment we're
trying to get them to give the birds
more space natural light change the
genetics all these basic things we're
not asking them to go vegan we're asking
them to just give the birds a little
more space are they vertically
integrated so they're not getting their
chickens from Purdue they're basically
responsible for getting their own
their suppliers title and Tyson is the
main make this their main supplier in
the United States and they have we
launched a big campaign against them
we've done on the ground in person
meetings they are not budging and their
competitors are so Popeye is last week
announced their first big chicken chain
said we're gonna make these commitments
we're gonna do all these things you're
asking us to do
Burger King did it subway did it
McDonald's is refusing can see OKC not
yes but I'm hopeful and KFC at least is
exploring some plant-based options in
fact I think today they're doing trials
in for their playmates nugget in
Nashville and Charlotte oh wow and the
same one that they did in Atlanta so
it's super exciting and but McDonald's
is behind the times and I they're their
leadership needs to wake up it's not
okay to ignore the very obvious
suffering that they're responsible for
McDonald's in this country is
responsible for half a billion chickens
and their supply chain per year they
purchase is it just an old guard
management team like the c-suite is just
out of out of step with the times or
their leadership keeps changing they
have a new president this year
and I I find it difficult to understand
how they're maintaining their position I
mean they are their argument is
something like nobody else really
believes what they're doing they're just
telling you that they're gonna move in
this direction to get you off their
backs and you know we're really looking
at it and that's just that's nonsense
mmm McDonald's yeah what are you doing
yeah and uh you know I think the
excitement over Burger King doing the
impossible burger is not something to be
ignored no not at all yeah I mean that's
a huge deal
and you know Popeyes just made this
commitment and that's exciting because
Popeyes you know it's one of the first
big chicken chain and I think that will
cause other more of their competitors
say okay we can't keep treating chickens
like this we have to give them more
space we have to do these basic
so we all agree in the science agrees
that are necessary that the birds as a
minimum should have right all right well
we gotta round this out but the the
final thing I kind of want to explore
with you is you know living inside the
mind if somebody who's listening to this
perhaps this is the first time they've
heard any of this they're like holy cow
like the chicken industry does what like
I didn't know like I you know I need to
change what is the advice that you give
to somebody or how do you direct that
person you know to start to make changes
in their life with respect to the diet
choices that they're making especially
if their look I'm I'm busy I'm on a
budget I work two jobs I got a bunch of
kids like you know I'm not gonna be able
to just snap my fingers and make the
whole family go vegan overnight but I
really like wow you know this is not
okay with me the advice we always give
is one step at a time do one day one
meal if it's too hard to do one day and
move incrementally in the right
direction and every step is progress
every one of those steps is progress
every one every time you're choosing not
to eat the animals you are contributing
to reducing their suffering to
increasing happiness joy on this planet
and so you don't have to do it all just
one meal you can do one day one week one
month and then it can turn into what you
can achieve what you can do I think it's
more about what start with what you can
and do that first not what should I do
but what can you do yeah don't let
perfection be the enemy of progress that
is my motto for sure one step at a time
and you know go get your beyond chicken
yeah it's available like everywhere now
it's exciting you know it's cool and
pick up grilled pickup grills right yeah
your independent bookstore or on Amazon
it's really a great read yeah yeah
really lovely job with the book because
it's sort of part memoir but also kind
of investigation
you know like thriller for a little bit
and then this you know painting this
picture for you know the future that we
all want to live in so I loved it you
did a really amazing job and and you are
a hero in this movement I have so much
respect for the work
that that you've done that you are doing
and then I know that you will do and
nothing but love and support and please
consider me a resource I want to help
out in any way I can so thank you for
your advocacy and your and your hearts
and your passion well thank you for
giving animals platform for these issues
it's my great that your heart an honor
to talk hearts in this cool all right
peace
[Music]